SEASON.
>> Joe: HE I I
MIKA ZIBANEJ GET IT TO
KREIDER AND BACK TO ZIBANEJAD.
FOX STEPS UP AND SHON POWER
PLAY GOALS IS CHRIS KREIDERRYAN.
BROTHER OF THE EDMONDTON.
IT'S CLEARED
OILERS DEFENSEMAN.
SCORE!Y GEORGIEV.INTO
THE R25 WAS THE TIME OF THE SCO
AND GIVING THE RANGERS
McDAVID.
NURSE WITH A
PUCK BROUGHT UP BYN THE PLAY IS
THER McKEGG.
LINDGREN.
KREIDER.
ZIBANEJAD FOR KREIDER JUST
MISSED.
BIG HIT.
TYLER OUT OF THE ZONE.O
KREIDER.
WITH THE  FACE-OFFS IN
THE FIRST PERIOD?
OILERS 10-4 ON GOT A COUPLE OF
OPTIONS TOWARDS NET OR TO THE P.
6:26 GONE BY IN THE SECOND
PERIOD.
YOU KNOW WHAT RANGERS
TROUBA.
PULJUJARVI ON THE OILERS POWER .
>> Joe: ZIBANEJAD NEARLY MADE .
GAUTHIER GOT A PIECE OF 6:00 TO
PERIOD.
KYLE TURRIS.
BENSON.
DEFLECTION.
GL
EDMONDTON UPAUSE IS
CONCENTRATING DEFENSIVELY A AT
BESTDEFENSEMAN.
>> Sam: MOU'RE
HERE.
GET TICKETS AT NEW YORK YAMAMOT.
A BRILLIANT SAVE BY
HE STROME.
TOWARD THE NET AND DEFLECTION
AND SCORE!LEAD.
DRAISAITL GOT IT THROUGH TOO